誰もいないね朝は
おはようございます はじめしゃちょーです
ただいま朝の6:20になっております
僕はとあるアイテムを見つけてしまいました
こちら
切断された手首でございます
ほら
ここはでもねあんまりクオリティ高くないんんですよね
腕の方はかなりクオリティ高くて
オイラの腕とね大きさがほぼ同じなんすよほら
クオリティはかなり高いんで
今回こんな朝から僕は何をしようと言いますと
たまたま僕を知ってる人が来ると
で、まずどうぞ握手しましょうみたいな感じで
握手をします
握手するときの僕の手がもし急に落ちたらっていうドッキリでございます
こういう感じだね
どう？
カメラマン）全然わからないよ
はじめ）わからないでしょ？
こんな感じです
こんな感じで
握手を求めますと
で、このまま抜いても不自然なので
あ、あの握手いいですか？
全然いいですよ！
うわやべぇ恥ずかしいな
握手かー
やべぇちょっとミスった
握手してもらっていいですか？
あーもう全然いいですよ
緊張するなー
やべぇ緊張する
握手ですか？
（不穏なBGM）
流れはまさにそんな感じです
朝なので
フレッシュな朝に
爽やかなドッキリで
迎えようと思います
では行こう
よろしくお願いします
今のどう？
いい感じ
はじめ）こんにちは
はじめ）よかったら握手しませんか？
腕が取れるドッキリです
握手しましょう握手しましょう
ファンの人）いいですか？
ファンの人）うわビックリした！
よっしゃよっしゃー
お疲れ様でした
カメラマン）お疲れ様です
というわけで腕が落ちるドッキリ
あのー
まあ5、6人の方に仕掛けたんですけど
いまいちリアクションが薄いぞ
まあ、でも最後はね
最後の男の子はちゃんとビックリしてくれてたんで
今回の腕のドッキリ
使えない
～＾ED＾～